>>Well thanks very much for your questions
and your posting. I don't agree. We've got
to make sure that growth and the environment
are not alternatives, but they go together.
We need green growth. So I don't think that
there is some set level of growth that if
you exceed you'll necessarily damage the environment.
We gonna make sure that growth can go along
with perfecting our environment. How do we
do that? For instance,we're gonna make sure
that when it comes to electricity generation,
and distribution, and use. We have a smart-grid
that people can interact with. That you can
produce your own electricity. You can sale
the surplus back to the grid. You can plug
in electric cars. You can make possible the
renewable energies that can be need to be
used bulk like tidal,wind,wave and solar power.
So these things mustn't be alternative. The
role of politicians is we've got to work at
is how you make growth and greenery go together.
And I thinik that it's particulary important
that in a recession, we don't junk our committment
to the environment and tackling climate change.
I think it's tempting for politicians to say
"Look of course the prority must be everything
to do with the recession, let'sforget about
the environment. That would be a mistake.
We gonna make sure we do things now that help
people to get out of the recession,to get
jobs,and that help businesses,but are also
good for environment in the future. And investing
in green technology and green businesses and
green ideas for the future is one that would
work very well